foreign
crypto derivatives platform and the best
place to buy your Bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the Leia
Heil pen show we are doing an emergency
update about FDX and the entire crypto
crash that we've seen over the last 24
hours and I have a very special guest
who's going to give us his take on what
is happening but before I start the show
I do want to let you know that this is
sponsored by the OG crypto derivatives
exchange that now has a spot exchange
bitmex so if you are looking for a more
reliable place to buy your
cryptocurrency from and your Bitcoin
then I'm going to leave all the links
for you in the description below um so
there you go that will be bitmex now
before I bring my guests on please don't
forget to hit the like button and
subscribe so you never miss a video
alright guys let's kick this off joining
me today is crypto YouTuber entrepreneur
and very successful Trader it's Carl
roonerfelt or as everyone else knows him
it is the moon Carl welcome to the show
how are you today
hey I'm doing uh okay but uh if the
market was better I would be incredible
I know I we were chatting earlier and I
think we agreed that this has to be
probably one of the worst events that
we've seen in crypto probably worse than
Mount gox what is your take on what has
just happened over the last 24 hours
yeah so I agree with you here that like
what's happened here in the past few
days could have easily been an episode
of the TV show billions or any other
like dramatic American TV series you
know it's really really
[Music]
um
it's mind-blowing honestly like I I I
made some live streams on my channel in
the past couple of days and many times I
was sitting there like just speechless
like I don't even know what to say
anymore like
um it's just so huge having the two
biggest exchanges clashing like that and
it has major implications for for us in
Crypts even if even if you didn't lose
money in FTX you're losing money all
across the board and even if you didn't
you're still
like the damage and the reputational
damage of crypto in general could have
severe consequences for us for the next
couple of years so
um this definitely has the same kind of
um
ring to it like Mount Cox Luna Celsius
um I would say FTX is way worse than
Celsius of course and and maybe even
bigger than Luna in terms of money I
think it's by far I I don't know the
exact numbers but I think uh the whole
FTX um
thing is worth like 150 billion or
something like we're talking about a lot
of money
that is just potentially just Vanishing
right in front of our eyes now so
it's crazy
it is so crazy and I think this has
taken everybody
um it's sort of been a shock because I
feel like people trusted FTX um you know
they had Tom Brady backing them they had
the
magma freed which you know we all sort
of trust and end up sort of you know
doing an Alex machinski on us
yeah I'm I'm very shocked I I've seen
these things happen before but that FTX
would do this uh that caught me by by
surprise just like anyone else I think
um fortunately I didn't have money in
FTX I think I may have had a little bit
but like if it was it was probably
nothing
um but
but I I could have easily easily
I could have very easily had a few
million dollars there because I I have
millions of dollars in different
exchanges so FTX would have definitely
been an exchange I could have trusted
with uh with millions of dollars
um just like I trust buying us or buy a
bit or these other exchanges so I think
it's very scary that FTX went down
because who's next you know
um that's the that's the question like
because
not people say that blockchain is very
transparent and it is true but it's only
transparent if uh if the companies give
you access to the the actual wallets and
and if you have full
you know insight into to the balance
sheet which is not always the case so in
this case I think that it wasn't always
very transparent maybe and it seems like
FTX in the background has been doing
things that uh are simply immoral and uh
very irresponsible and as soon as the
market turns
um it becomes a the Celsius effect where
it just goes to zero so that's
um very very sad
yeah I think we should start asking
these exchanges to uh you know publicly
show their balance sheet I mean I know
binance this morning actually just um
showed that their proof of reserves and
they're holding you know billions so you
know they sort of feel like they're
going to be okay maybe that's what we
have to do
um but you said you didn't hold anything
on FTX but you don't have to tell me how
much you have or haven't lost but have
you lost anything just in general with
everything crashing Bitcoin ethereum um
you know Solana obviously like have you
lost much
biblical amounts oh my God yeah it's I
lost more money than hundreds of people
making hundreds of lifetimes so I try to
think about it but it is a lot of money
I've lost the money that could have
bought me um big businesses
bought me nice watches from cars or or
even like skyscrapers you know um but I
tried to not um think like that because
first of all
it's only lost if you realize the loss
um second of all money comes quickly and
goes quickly it comes and goes I always
because throughout my like five years of
crypto four or five years
I've lost money many many times and back
in the days when I lost like ten
thousand dollars for me that was like
insane I thought wow I'm never gonna
recover but in the next couple of years
I had one day I made like a hundred
thousand you know so you lose money but
you can also make money and I try to
um zoom out when these things happen and
realize that um
as long as you have your health as long
as you have your mind your mindset and
you're still you know I mean I'm young
you're young like we have decades in
front of us to make money so
um I think that it's it's bad to stare
blindly on on the losses you make today
because you you can easily make 10x that
in the in the future so
um but yeah but it should not go on set
I I I lost a lot of money
yeah you're right an abundance mindset
there's so much more money to there's so
much more money to make and I think
you're totally right you know it's only
a loss if you sell
um I've lost like hundreds of thousands
but I haven't sold anything so I'm just
you know holding tight waiting for the
next waiting for the next Bull Run
because I think you know Bitcoin for
sure is going back up that's inevitable
um so what is your biggest holding um
can you tell us what you know made you
the most money in crypto so far
hmm my biggest holding is Bitcoin by far
when it comes to my um like liquid
cash which I would of course say it's
it's all crypto it's no actual cash but
um then I have my net worth is also
locked up in like you know Equity or or
you know just company valuations but if
you talk about only my liquid cash
reserves it's like 80 Bitcoin maybe 10
or 15 percent maybe ethereum and then
like five ten percent
um other coins
um right now in the at the top of the
bull market
uh it was very different because I've
invested in 400 crypto startups and um
at the very top of the bull market there
were some pretty crazy uh returns where
I
for example like
every now and then I put like maybe
twenty thousand dollars in a project and
at the very top
at the peak of the the chart it could be
worth six million seven million
um I had a few of those examples where I
invested in um star Atlas for example I
put like fifteen thousand dollars at the
top it was like four million dollars
um so I had some crazy months where
their evaluations skyrocketed but as we
all know these times are over since a
long time now and most of that value is
gone uh but I'm happy that I actually
did take some profits out of these um
this um Investments at least so they
recovered my initial I made some on top
of that but in the bull market there's a
time to make money uh now is the time to
build and save and invest cautiously
um I I don't spray and pray anymore uh
that's for sure but um but yeah
yeah the only thing I'm buying right now
is Bitcoin I I just I wouldn't touch
anything else especially not ethereum
um only Bitcoin
um so can you you talk to us about where
the major support is I know seventeen
thousand dollars was obviously a major
support we broke that
um although we have we have bounce but
where's the major support and do you
think that we're going lower or do you
think we actually
um already hit the bottom at I think it
was fifteen thousand five hundred
dollars
well I've always said that
so on my YouTube channel when I make my
technical analysis I always
say these things like if this then that
so basically I've told my audience that
if Bitcoin breaks below this like 18
000 support 19 18 000 then that is uh
with a very high likelihood going to
lead to a drop down to
um 13 to 11k and I have no reason to
like change that now like we broke down
to a 1716 even touched uh the higher 15s
there so it looks like uh Bitcoin is
heading down towards testing the 13 to
11k region
is that guaranteed no but it really
seems like that because the trend is
your friend that's like technical
analysis 101 if the trend is going down
it is way likelier that the trend
continues down at any point in time
rather than randomly reversing
um that said there will be a reversal at
some point but we need to find the signs
and clues for it for example it could be
a double bottom pattern that's like one
of the best reversal patterns or a
beautiful falling wedge or something
that makes us um go back up or like the
the best thing would be maybe like an
inverse head and shoulders I love to see
those break back up but right now we
have nothing like that so no hope in in
the next couple of weeks for now oh man
I definitely think we're going lower as
well I just think that times are so
crazy right now there's all these weird
things happening behind the scenes you
know we didn't know that Sam bankman
freed and you know fds's balance sheet
we didn't know they were insolvent and
so there's all these weird things
happening and I I just don't think we're
done I do agree I think thirteen
thousand fourteen thousand is is
definitely likely um out of Interest
have you ever met Sam Bachman freed and
either way what do you think of him
I never met Sam I did meet CZ many times
but uh Sam I don't have a big opinion
about him I just always thought he looks
like like a nerdy
I think he played World of Warcraft his
whole life
um but as a professional I think um he
is definitely you know a genius I would
say
um but
um you know I I don't really have like
an opinion about him I I didn't like
when he was like talking too much about
regulation and stuff so I guess that was
not so nice
yeah he he pushes a lot of defy and
regulation generally um you know Bill
Clinton was speaking at his event
um in the Bahamas he actually gave the
second biggest donation to uh Biden's
presidential campaign a lot of people
say that he's sort of the the
establishment's puppet I actually saw
last night that FDX are part of the
world economic Forum what's your take do
you think he could be some kind of like
puppet of the establishment or is this
just another day in crypto
um yeah you know what I I must say I
I really don't have having a good idea
about Sam mcmanfried
I I think that when it comes to FTX
buyers these massive exchanges
it seems a little bit naive to think
that
there's no governments involved somehow
because there's so much power in those
exchanges look at binance like it's
maybe one of the biggest companies in
the world if not maybe the biggest at
the top of the bull market in terms of
you know evaluation power and everything
so
it's safe to assume that there are big
actors and players that are looking at
these
um companies and they they want to to
have their
their say and their piece of the pie and
and maybe control them so so I think
that there's definitely something there
and I mean if Sam is in World economic
Forum if he's there like yeah it's
almost like it could be some kind of
some secret rooms there
um I've been there myself but only as
like a spectator not as an invited
um
you know reptile or something
how
um well I again I was not invited
um officially so it was very tough for
me to get into like the crazy places but
I was able to sink into a certain uh
places where I could see the the CEO of
like you know Goldman Sachs and these
people walking around there it was a
little bit crazy and this was way back
by the way when I just had my YouTube
channel I had like I don't know 30 000
subscribers I was a really like you know
nobody up there but I was walking around
there were all these crazy people you
know uh all the the craziest
billionaires and like celebrities of the
world are in doubles once a year you
know
um so that was interesting but uh but to
get invited to the secret rooms there I
think you really have to be really
involved in the in the dark secret rooms
oh yeah I did think I'd go even if I uh
got an invitation would you go
I think I would yeah
yeah I want to see what they say when
we're not listening when when we can you
know but that's the thing I don't think
I would be invited because it's way too
uh Secrets they're they're controlling
the world from there
yeah I'm with you
um so in terms of crypto then what coins
are you most bullish on long term and
what do you look at how do you make that
decision
I'm most bullish on bitcoin long term
that's that's always going to be the
case for me it doesn't matter who has
the craziest best idea or even if I have
my own companies like Bitcoin will out
survive any one of us all of us forever
so if you want to take low risk while
still being able to make money just put
your money in Bitcoin and keep it there
hold it there
um forever and um that that's that's the
only recommendation I can always do
without feeling bad without feeling like
someone might might lose however it's
also very important that people that buy
Bitcoin hold it because some people they
buy and as soon as it goes down 50 they
sell the key is to buy and hold for at
least the next cycle which means that
you always have to hold at least four
years based on these four-year Cycles
then it's like
very very very hard to lose
yeah that's what that's exactly my my
play right now um I'm so down so I'm
just holding until until we're back up
um so how long do you think this bear
Market is gonna last
um I think
um at least two years now we're gonna
have a pretty tough boring time I think
um that's just based on the previous
cycles and um
based on the fact that markets go up and
down and sometimes we have to suffer for
a while to to deserve the next bull
market and um yeah so two years I think
and um
yeah I'm prepared for that you know I I
lost a lot of money my my burn rates are
higher now than they were
um or they're not higher but percent
wise they're higher now percentage-wise
so uh but this is this is business you
know that's how it works and um you just
have to
um keep building keep investing uh just
more cautiously and more responsibly and
then competition goes out which is great
because then there's less competitors
and then you can actually grow faster uh
this is something binance is doing now
as you can see binance going absolutely
crazy and um speaking of buying this I I
am a little bit actually like scared of
how large binance will become in this
bear Market because they are the only
ones who have like
disgusting amount of money so they can
just go out there and like buy and and
you know acquire and they grow even more
so they grow more in the bear Market
than in the bull market actually
because of the market share they're
taking over now and in the next bull
market they will honestly they might be
like twice the size of Amazon soon who
knows like it's it's really scary
because it becomes a monopoly and um I
mean I love competition and capitalism
so I think everyone should have their
own you know so so in a way it's fair
that binders is doing it because it's
just the market right but it's also
scary because having someone controlling
the whole market like that it's the
opposite of what decentralization is
supposed to be right so then we have one
company binance controlling all of
crypto maybe soon they they have like 90
of the market and if you think about it
if that becomes reality
then there is one Central Authority that
can be very easily manipulated
governments can come in and immediately
control the whole crypto space because
they control binance and then that
becomes a risk for the whole Space
because uh regulators and governments
can come in and take control very easily
because there's one Central authority to
to regulate and I think that's very sad
and scary but um I don't know I mean do
you do what do you think I mean
Regulators must come in and and look at
this now and see that they want to do
something
yeah I actually agree with you that was
actually one of my concerns with um FTX
because FTX obviously bought so much
they were buying blockfi they were
buying up you know
um web 3 and all these different things
so that was my concern with them and
then I was concerned that binance were
going to buy FTX and then own everything
FTX owns and then you have these massive
um monopolies but I don't know look I
mean this is such a bad sort of mindset
but
because it's all about being trustless
but I kind of trust CZ which is also
really bad you shouldn't put your trust
in one Central
um place
um but I I just I just don't know
um ultimately all you can do is you know
obviously encourage people not to leave
their keys on it you know yeah I mean
exactly so I also like in a way I trust
buyers I trust CC because they're too
big to like screw me over right they
wouldn't do that uh but I would have
also said the same about the F6 to be
honest
um but um but who knows like when CZ and
binance is massive there and then the
the governments come in like does it
matter how much he trusts CZ if he has
no choice what if Regulators come in and
say like you have to comply with this
otherwise we shut you off in Europe or
we shut you off in in us where we shut
you off you know and then
maybe he just feels like the pressure is
too high and then immediately he he
complies with uh regulators and with
governments and and the little guy
um gets screwed over I mean this is
possible I'm not saying it's gonna
happen but like sure he's he's probably
a great guy I I met him like I said in
real life we've been talking we've been
following each other for a couple of
years I I really like the guy like we've
been having great discussions in great
conversations so I I would never say
anything bad about him I'm just saying
that like
governments are very powerful and if
they come knocking on the door like I'm
sure
things can change pretty quickly you
know
um because really quickly as you were
speaking uh sign back with freed has
just
um done a thread which I just want to
bring up right now he's he's tweeting
live He's I think he's just apologized
hang on wow it's a 20 Page thread oh my
God let me scroll up here we go he says
I'm sorry that's the biggest thing I
[ __ ] up and should have done better I
also have been communicating more very
recently transparency transparently my
hands were tied during the duration of
the possible Finance deal I wasn't
particularly allowed to say much
publicly but of course it's on me and
that we ended up here in the first place
there's 20 of these I'll just read one
more before we get into it so here's an
update on where things are this is about
FDX International The non-us Exchange
FTS users blah blah blah FDX
International currently has a total
market value of assets collateral higher
than client deposits but but that's the
difference from liquidity delivery as
you can tell from the state of
withdrawals the currency varies widely
okay I'll have to read this later but
this is crazy so he's broken the silence
basically
he's broken the silence I mean this is
nuts it is Matt and he seems to be
taking on all the responsibility
right that's what is yeah
yeah I mean it's just crazy I feel like
this totally could have been avoided
um but anyway I'll read more of that in
a bit I also wanted to get your take
though um on ethereum proof of stake
versus proof of work ethereum's
obviously had the merge
um you know what's your take on the
merge are you still bullish on ethereum
at all um you know would she prefer
proof of sake or proof of work
to be perfectly honest with you like I I
wouldn't be the guy to like
talk too much about like the technicals
of ethereum I I am very bullish in
ethereum because of the market charity
theorem has and the amount of
um you know track record and the the
amount of apps built there the
developers working on it
um if if proof of work or proof of stake
is the best
to be perfectly honest with you like
there are pros and cons with both and I
I couldn't tell you
um you know I would have to trust the
computer nerds too to kind of advise me
on that uh but um but I'm very excited
about the this kind of experiment almost
I guess we could call it you know going
from proof of State uh work through
stake and uh see how that
um impacts the fundamentals but also the
price because of course theoretically
the price uh should go up from here but
people they expected an immediate price
increase but these things doesn't happen
like that it's more about like the next
one two years I would say just like when
um central banks change interest rates
you don't see the effect immediately it
takes you one to two years for the
actual economic effect to take place or
at least that's how the theory goes and
historically it has been so
um
I think this uh could potentially lead
to just a very very strong ethereum in
the next bull market against uh Bitcoin
and against other competitors
potentially but I'm not expecting
ethereum to necessarily outperform
anything else right now that's that's
not what I see
okay so Carl I hate to do this but I'm
going to put you on the spot a little
bit where do you think Bitcoin is going
to be five years from now and where do
you think ethereum is going to be five
years from now we won't hold you to this
okay Bitcoin will be worth more than a
million dollars uh five years from now
uh ethereum it's very tough I really
don't know I would have to just say
something random that I don't even have
so much uh because
but logically if Bitcoin goes to a
million dollars
I would have to say that ethereum
I could easily be between ten to twenty
thousand dollars something like this
um but but Bitcoin being above a million
I'm actually quite confident in um still
I've been saying it for multiple years
now but but now I'm still holding to
that
damn Karina days are truly coming that
would be I think everyone could really
could really use that
um so out of Interest how did you
actually make most of your money and
your success was it through trading or
simply holding Bitcoin um in the early
days
um it's actually a big mix of many
different things
um but some people think I only made it
from Bitcoin from law or only from
Trading but actually it's a very big mix
of many things in the very beginning it
actually started with my YouTube channel
um I started some small trading so small
investing I started my YouTube channel I
started talking publicly about crypto
um led to me building a small capital
from from different affiliate
Partnerships and so on and this capital
is what I used for my trading for my
investments
um and um
then I made a lot of money from
investing in startups I I invested in
over 400 crypto startups and that was
obviously a very very uh aggressive
thing but in the bull market it really
works you know because everything is
pumping
um so I invested probably in
let's say 80 of all the things I
invested are probably going to go to
zero at some point because it's not
possible that all of them are surviving
just like back in the.com bubble if you
invested in 100.coms probably 90 of them
are now worthless pieces of just.coms
that are nothing but
chances are you you got Amazon Google
Facebook and these things you know so
that's basically what I'm doing so I
have a bunch of tokens just waiting for
um a Green Day in the future and I'm
holding some of them for the next five
years uh but I made some money from that
uh I also am a very large liquidity
provider in um centralized and
decentralized exchanges so I I provide
liquidity and I make a lot of money from
essentially having money that's like one
good thing about having money you can
actually make money from just having
money
um
and um and yeah and I have my my own
companies as well uh which make anything
from low Revenue to to high Revenue
um right now it's a bear market so it's
of course way less now but in the next
bull market I'm expecting some good
returns from those as well so but yeah
as you can hear it's like a big mix of
many many different things
um but uh yeah
yeah that's amazing
um and obviously I know you trade so do
you day trade do you swing trade and
also what kind of temperament do you
need to be a Trader I know some people
are there Apple nights staring at the
screens they don't say more than two
words to people a day like you know what
kind of temperament you need
um first of all I was never day trader
uh that was not for me because I have
too much ADHD which means that I I
cannot sit down and like Focus for too
too long you know I I um I need uh a
more passive way of trading and then
swing trading has been my way of trading
at least um back
you know
in the beginning of my career up until
like a couple of years ago I was doing a
lot of Swing trading it's been way less
lately because I have a lot of things on
my plate I am focusing a lot on my
companies my investments I have actually
um at this very moment probably still
like 140 employees so I I have a lot of
things on my mind so trading is uh less
of um a business I still do it but it's
not like my main income anymore
um but when I do trade it's only swing
trading I put the trade and I let it sit
there for at least a couple of days up
to like two weeks even sometimes you
know
um so it's more about waiting for trades
and and sometimes it can be three two
three weeks where I don't even have a
trade open because I don't really see a
point you know
um so I
I ca I don't sit in front of the charts
all day like this because it's just like
you know poker players like if you if
you're gonna be a proper like poker
player and like
um sit there with like these cash games
like then you need to grind like six
hours a day just sit in cash game like
this you know uh that's the day trader
um the tournaments players
um can do tournaments every now and then
maybe so I don't know if that's a good
um yeah it makes sense
yeah no I think it makes perfect sense
um you are actually once a cashier in
Sweden
um and now you move to Dubai living the
high life so can you tell me about your
beginnings and how you actually got into
crypto in the first place
yeah so I think it's an interesting
story because as you said only four
years ago
I was still working in a grocery store
as a cashier in Sweden and I actually
um it I think it was the 18th of
November 2018 so uh in eight days it's
my four year anniversary of uh quitting
my uh my grocery store job
congratulations that's exciting
that is crazy actually because people
that know me today they actually cannot
even believe it that it's true because
they know me as this entrepreneur you
know with my Bugatti flying private jets
like they they cannot imagine that only
four years ago I was still in a in a
grocery store in Sweden but the crazy
thing is that
I've learned that anything is possible
and it comes down to the mindset and the
Law of Attraction and I talk a lot about
this on on my my other channel my Carl
beautiful Channel which is more like a
lifestyle Vlog Channel because sometimes
when I get bored of crypto I want to go
and you know talk about like other
things and then I talk about mindset and
Law of Attraction and and if to make it
very simple
um everything around us our reality is
actually Just Energy
um everyone who has a little bit of like
a basic understanding of quantum physics
will know that
if you go down to the smallest part of
reality like the atoms and even within
the atoms you will find that there is
nothing there it's just strings of
vibrational energy it's almost like the
universe is just like a big Orchestra of
of a vibrating strings of energy and
when you understand this then you can
learn to
in a way change your Reality by changing
your internal energy because you are
also energy all of us are energy your
thoughts are energy your words are
energy your body is energy your your
your whole being so uh the Law of
Attraction very simply
um
states that like attracts like
in a particular way so if you think Rich
thoughts and happy thoughts and imagine
yourself
um in in certain environments then that
energy will attract that materially so I
know that it sounds like this is too
easy to be true but it is completely 100
true I'm a living proof of that because
how can you otherwise go from cashier to
this insane like lifestyle just in such
a short period of time
if there is not a little bit of magic
involved you know and um I truly believe
in in the law of attraction I I feel
like I'm a perfect example and um it's
quantum physics like the world we live
in is just a hologram just like this um
key here it's it doesn't actually exist
in any other form than just code or
information it's just information that
our five senses decode into something
that we perceive as solid and real but
it's actually not real it's just
it's just information just like in a
computer game if you play GTA or The
Sims if you have a car or a house within
the game it's not really there right
it's just ones and zeros it's just
computer code but with the computer
interface and all of the motherboards
and whatever electrical circuits it
actually decodes the
the
nonsense information or the perceived
nonsense information into something that
makes sense to our eyes
the the world works exactly the same so
um yeah that's a law of attraction and
and I was visualizing um actually I have
a very good example of this look
uh two days ago I was doing some spring
cleaning and I found all of my old
iPhones
um and this phone is an iPhone 6 that I
had when I was working in a grocery
store in Sweden and
the most interesting thing is the
background image which is a point of
view of um
yeah so I was in the grocery store
making what like one thousand five
hundred dollars per per month but I
changed my background image to this uh
private jet and
I'll show you also another thing in here
I was also crazy enough to download
um I don't know if you can see it but
this app get smarter it's like a uber
for private jets but I was working in
the grocery store that's amazing
and the funny thing I even went so far
that I even
I registered an account
um and I even asked for quotes how much
for me to fly from Sweden to France you
know and then quoted me like twenty
thousand dollars and I made like not
even that in one year but I did it
because I wanted to imagine myself like
as if I was already wealthy enough to do
that that was literally cashier and I
told my friends I was doing this they
thought I was stupid crazy but now
actually every other week I'm flying
private jets as if that's just like
normal for me so
it's it it is crazy how it works like I
really think that something simple like
this helps me attract this reality and
this is just one example I did many
things like my Bugatti I visualized it I
visualized freedom I visualized
traveling I visualized happiness
um so many things like everything
started with just an idea in my mind I
started visualizing it every day I
started telling myself every day things
like I I fly private jets or I have this
much money or I am happy I am successful
I am extraordinary if you tell yourself
these things day over day then you will
reprogramming reprogram your
subconscious into actually believing
these things
it's just like how propaganda works if
you repeat lie over and over eventually
you start believing it
um this has been tried by governments uh
for decades and it's still happening
today
um but you can also propaganda yourself
and it works actually you you can start
believing that you're rich and that
you're happy and then it becomes true
because the universe will answer your
energy
that's so beautiful that's so
fascinating um I also do believe in the
Law of Attraction there's a lot of
different things which I've been able to
manifest but um I'm interested so you so
is it just like a daily thing you'll
just like say certain things do you
write it down do you like meditate on it
and visualize or is it as simple as just
sort of like you know changing the
background on your phone and just sort
of acting as if you know downloading the
app like practically what it what is
what does it look like
so I I do not do a lot of meditation I
want to start doing that but I I must
admit that this is something I don't do
much
um but I really do believe in meditation
um what I have done though is that
my very very first steps was I wrote
down my goals on like a piece of paper
um I also every time before I went to
bed I always just closed my eyes and I
literally told myself like
I'm rich I'm happy I'm extraordinary I
have um I have this I have that I make
this much money I have this much money
you know just whatever came to my mind
like two minutes every night I said
things over and over and every night I
came up with new things but I just said
things that made me feel like yeah this
is what I want to be so I just said it
but I always said it as if it's already
true so you should never say I want this
new car you should always say I have
this new car I have this thing or I I am
this I am successful
um and so this I did for for like a long
time and then eventually like one or one
and a half years later I started to you
know see my life change uh but it's an
ongoing process because of course as
soon as I started making like
ten thousand dollars a month uh that was
already a huge number for me that was
like life changing that meant I am free
I can travel yeah do whatever I want you
know uh but I always upped my goals
because I thought if I can reach ten
thousand dollars a month from working in
a grocery store then where's the limit
I'm sure there's no limit I can just go
crazy so I've been going literally crazy
like when when people hear my friends
and my my you know ideas they think I'm
I'm uh I'm insane I need a mental
hospital or something but but I think
that's that's almost
um needed you have to be crazy enough to
believe that these things are possible
to actually be able to uh to attract it
because
that's how the universe works you know I
think people they believe in the wrong
things they believe in the propaganda
from the government
that you're just a slave to society that
you have to go to school and then you
have to work for someone your whole life
with something that you don't even want
to work with you know officially people
think that that's how life is supposed
to live and if you think so if you
believe that then that you will attract
more of that reality and that's very sad
so fortunately I was able to break free
from the notion of what's normal and
what's supposed to be and I'm crazy
enough to to believe in the UN
Unthinkable and it looks like you're the
same you know because you're also very
successful you're doing crazy things and
I can see that you're very successful
with your own personal brand and your
your social media and everything so I'm
sure you're just as crazy as me and um I
mean we are the people that will will be
there to be able to inspire people and
um that's what I try to do now on a
daily basis inspire people to do the
same
um I'm trying to go more and more into
that rather than just crypto because I
think that the mindset and like these
kind of things Law of Attraction it
really means so much more than just
crypto you know because you can apply
anything money relationships happiness
health whatever it is you can really
change your life so yeah but um but now
I went off on the tangent but no it's
good no it's great it's great I think
what you've done is amazing and no I
totally agree with you I actually used
to have a book that I used to write in
and I'd write it um as if I had already
achieved something
um and then two years later I reread the
book and I was like damn I got that and
more which is which is truly crazy
um no I think it's so great to inspire
people because people often don't
realize that there's so much more than
just a nine to five and they don't
realize that you really don't have to
work that hard to live a good life you
just need to work very smart
um you know and and know people so
people don't always realize that
um so so how's living in Dubai what's it
like I know the rest of the world seems
to be crumbling it seems to be uh going
really woke and really weird but Dubai
seems to be uh you know the center of
where it's all happening what's it like
living in Dubai well when it comes to
crypto is by far the fastest growing
Market I think it's really crazy how
much crypto businesses are coming here
we have you know Finance even FTX
ironically got their license like five
days ago in the UAE
um so that's uh that went well that was
a quick five days
um but so we have FTX uh buy a bit
um many of the big extensions are coming
here setting up headquarters here um I
have my head recorders here this is my
office I have
I have many employees and many of them
are in Dubai and I want to inspire more
and more of my employees to actually
come to Dubai because I think that Dubai
is the future of crypto
um for sure and then
the safety here is just absolutely
so sharing yeah because I I have had
some incidents around the world where
where safety has been an issue
especially when you're a public person
when you're known for being wealthy
especially in crypto it's like the worst
nightmare you can think of you know
famous wealthy in crypto because
everyone knows that crypto like it's you
know it's not money in a bank like you
know people they think they can just
like go up to me and say yeah send me
some Bitcoin
um so protection is very very key for me
so I have bodyguards everywhere I go in
the world
um if I travel with I never travel with
anything expensive I leave everything in
Dubai
um but I don't like this you know I
don't want to have to change my life uh
too much and this is the downside of
being well known by the way so
um
it is yeah it's just like something I
had to deal with I actually never
visualized Fame by the way this is
something that came just as a business
um I actually never really wanted to be
famous to be honest
um
not true seven eight years ago I I
actually wanted to be a famous musician
I remember this
um but with crypto it was always more
just I just love Bitcoin I love crypto
and the YouTube channel and stuff was
more just like an idea of like let's
let's see if I can make money and make a
business out of this but being famous
was actually never am and um a goal I
never had this as a goal but now I am
famous and I have to just deal with that
there's upsides and downsides it's good
for networking but it's uh it's also
like
I mean you're also famous right so I
guess you're also seeing the upsides and
downsides with it there's um pros and
cons with everything but um for business
it's good for sure yeah I think I
actually tweeted and you replied to it
the other day about um when you're when
you're um when you're famous people
don't see you as human anymore and so
they don't treat you as human like they
like they can't associate they can't
like relate to you anymore so they don't
treat you as human like I was in a bar
um the other night and some guys they
knew me and well they knew me from
online they didn't actually know me so
they came up to me to speak with me
which was fine but they start like
touching my back my shoulder and I'm
like hang on we don't know we don't know
each other like
stop touching me it's not touching me
you know so yeah it is it is weird and I
do keep hearing that to buy is really
really safe like the Law and Order there
is good so yeah it's amazing and some
people they say that oh it's because
they chop off your hands if you do
something bad yeah it's like your
parents but I'm not sure if that's true
because first of all I never heard
anyone getting their hands chopped off
um I don't think that's actually
happening
um and second of all I think it's just a
great mix of cultures here for some
reason like I don't know
how it works but for some reason the
culture here is just you know you don't
screw people over you don't steal things
and um yeah I mean it's also not really
true because there's a lot of scammers
here unfortunately like in crypto
there's a lot of scammers here
unfortunately and this is something that
is the um the price you have to pay for
allowing all crypto to come in here in
crypto there's a lot of cameras we all
know this right
um but in terms of like actual like
violence and and uh and theft you don't
see that at all amazing it's amazing so
I can walk around with my my watch I can
walk around with like alone women can
walk around alone in the middle of the
night anywhere here it's all fine it's
completely safe and that's unheard of in
in Europe for example in Europe you
can't uh it's very dangerous actually in
Europe and I've seen that firsthand and
um I have many examples of friends
getting like guns to their heads you
know and it's really crazy
yeah I'm not walking around by myself
alone anywhere maybe Dubai that's yeah
I'm in Miami right now okay I heard
Miami is also pretty dangerous
yeah it is I mean where I am I feel
perfectly safe but yeah I wouldn't walk
alone at night
um
you know it's it's not like London but
yeah it's Miami it's it's America
America is not safe at all
um yeah yeah everything most countries
are going to [ __ ] right now I think
it's just uh the global Trend and um we
just have to deal with that
and um
yeah Dubai might be my next stop I'm not
sure I have to see
um but what do you do you have any final
words for Words of Wisdom on these
bloodbath days
um you know how can we lift people's
spirits and also how can people um
follow you and stay up to date with um
your journey and everything that you're
doing
uh yeah first of all I think that look
at the long term like I said money goals
money comes money goes you lose some you
win some
um I lost a lot of money back in the
days but I made everything back later so
don't be uh don't be uh I mean if people
knew how much money I've lost in
different things like either to scams or
to
um an exchange breaking down or like
some T5 protocol breaking these things
have happened to me I've lost so much
money that
in the moment I felt like I just wanted
to cry and just like feel like
everything is over and like how am I
ever gonna come back from this
um but every single time I came back
from it and I realized that money is
just money
um literally it's just money like it it
doesn't really it shouldn't
control you it should only um enable you
uh in in times when you have an
abundance of it and if you have an
abundance mindset then money will always
have an a way of coming to you so
don't lose your mindset if you lose your
mindset that's when you truly break down
that's when you lost it all so um keep
your mindset that's that's uh no one can
ever take that away from you even if
they take all your money or your house
to take everything your mindset is key
um so so that's number one uh my socials
like I I have my YouTube channel the
moon where I do crypto analysis I have
my Vlog Channel called roonafelt which
is this name right there where I try to
inspire people to live their best
possible life possible become their most
extraordinary version of themselves
um I do that by by bragging about all
the expensive stuff I'm buying
um and um yeah I'm really I'm really
trying to do it to to inspire people
um then on Twitter the moon Carl
um you know I I make crypto tweets about
stuff sometimes some [ __ ] supposedly
sometimes I provide value but um yeah
that's what I do but I want to give you
a shout out you've done a great job I
can see that you're
growing very fast I think you're doing a
little YouTube Twitter and Instagram and
I can see your videos popping up all the
time nowadays you're really doing a good
job
thank you so much I really appreciate
that yeah I feel like in this world
which is just crumbling uh taking
matters into our own hand is sort of
like the only thing we can do
um but I want to thank you so much for
coming on it's been such a pleasure um
hearing about your story hearing your
take on what's going on right now
um and everyone please go and follow um
Carl especially on Instagram as well
because I love I love that that um you
know Law of Attraction mindset I love
everything of doing that I think that's
really inspiring um
you're focusing on like Instagram or or
crypto because you're doing like you're
doing crypto content that's how I knew
you from before like I've seen yourself
for like two years I think
um but now you're focusing also a little
bit on your like personal brand right
like I can see I love your Andrew
theater videos very funny
asking people on the street yeah thank
you so much yeah that was just oh my God
that's honestly the most uncomfortable
experience because just by the way every
time I go up to someone and ask them
what they think about Andrew take they
think because I'm like a sweet female
I'm gonna like agree with them and then
and then like you can see it in their
eye eyes that that's just like it just
changes
um but yeah I'm I'm sort of like yeah
focusing on just general
um
kind of like freedom and empowerment and
um sort of leaving the Matrix whether
it's like financially spiritually
personally
um you know relationship wise just
everyone just needs to do better and
kind of reject tradition reject like
everything the system is teaching you
um that's kind of what the route I'm
going down if that makes sense that's
amazing yeah but you should come to
Dubai I think this is the place to be I
mean if you if you want to grow even
more like you're going to become even
more like you should be somewhere where
it's more safe I think and there's so
much crypto stuff happening here I mean
I'm here all of the other crypto men of
the group
entity it has moved here as well
um many people are here I think this is
going to be the center of the the world
in the future when everything else Falls
I think Middle East is gonna you know
rise that's just what I think that's
just what I think I totally agree I I
might do I might come over Christmas
I'll have to see
um you know play it by ear see we'll see
what I'll do but I want to thank you so
much for coming on it's been such a
pleasure um everyone please if you're
not already follow Carl and don't forget
to hit the like button and subscribe and
we will see you all next week bye bye
foreign show